let's talk a bit about defamation in
section 230 because uh you're a lawyer
right that's a terrible segue too
that's actually pretty good we're
talking about big taxes
well we're talking about uh censorship
you've got uh people conservatives
getting banned left and right q gets
purged
but the rachel maddow conspiracy nuts
are given free pass right
so so i want to ask you a question cause
i was i remember was talking about i
think i was talking to will chamberlain
about this
and we've brought up several times for
those that aren't familiar section 230
basically gives broad immunities to
web what's the phrase they use um
interactive
web companies or internet service
providers there you go there you go
that basically means everybody for any
reason okay so what happens is
they can ban whoever they want
regardless of speech because they are
immunized from defamation as well as
long story short they won't have the
immunity taken from them if they do
moderate
however what's been happening is very
obviously
most of the bans happen on the right or
anti-establishment
some of the bans happen on the left but
it's usually like anti-war
anti-establishment leftist types
now the problem is many people on the
right seem to think there's a
distinction between a publisher and a
platform as if it matters it really
doesn't
the new york times has the same
protections as twitter
but something interesting does arise out
of this argument that i want to present
to you
first i'll start with uh the new york
times for instance right
if somebody writes for the writes an
article
and the new york times publishes on its
front page
what's the distinction between that and
say
someone writing a tweet and twitter
publishing it and putting it in its
what's happening bar to everybody in the
world
oh putting it in the in the what's
happening bar
right that's a much harder question
because if you would have just told if
you would you should have asked two
questions the first question was
what's the difference between the times
publishing an article
and a tweet we that's dumb though right
obvious questions that's why i said
twitter is just mechanically
so i don't know how they choose articles
for the what's happening bar they
editorialize oh they select a tweet and
then they write about it
or tweets okay so if they select a tweet
based on algorithms
the selection piece of it might be
content neutral in and of itself
although their algorithms are not
content neutral at all
but if they editorialize see again
we have to ask ourselves what's what do
we what what's the inquiry here why do
we care about this distinction
the the the simple answer to your
question is there's no difference
they are now publishers they are now
putting content into the world
for which they have the same
responsibility
as any as the new york times so when so
if john smith writes an article and the
new york times says we're going to put
that on the front page
the new york times is responsible for
the content in terms of live
defamation slander whatever libel right
okay if someone writes a tweet and then
twitter says we're going to put this in
our moment tab so everybody can see it
well curious as to what's the difference
but what's the editorial but okay so you
said they editorialized it's a really
well let's let's make sure i clarify
this so the
what's happening they'll put an
editorialization that's usually in
reference to a series of tweets so i
understand
they're liable for what they write there
but if i write an article for the new
york times
and then hand it to a guy and he goes i
will publish this in the front page
right he's the new york times assumes
responsibility for the contents of
that post if someone tweets and twitter
goes
i am going to put this in the moments
tabs that anyone who clicks it will see
it front and center
to hundreds of millions of people what's
the difference
it depends on what the reasonable
viewer understands from that tweet
and that's a fact question that has
never been
examined in a in a litigation setting
because
cases don't go this far and they need to
because i got another question for you
especially
if i'm handling them because i would
love to ask those questions let me ask
you a question
if ian wrote an article and posted it on
his blog
and then i took the contents of that
article and put on the front page of my
website what i assume responsibility for
publishing it
are you more than an aggregator are you
drudge report or are you this is to
this is tim poole and these are the
articles that i want you to read because
it
it
it appears on my front page identically
to every other article
every other so that's that's your
newspaper in other words
so if he licensed it he licensed the
article to you with the publisher
so if on your twitter account there's a
retweet from ian
that appears identically to your other
posts would your retweet then be
your responsibility as well yes
see this is where there's a lot of
questions that have never been asked and
we haven't seen people actually go to
court and start
challenging but this is one of the least
important questions see
and this as you understand because
you've spoken to will about this and
this is like a favorite ron and will
thing we wrote articles on this together
it hardly matters you know
the publisher versus platform
distinction is mostly irrelevant because
it has to do with
to what extent is twitter responsible
for what people tweet
meaning if i defame you in a tweet can
you sue twitter
why would you want to suit twitter
because coleman doesn't have any money
well coleman's not making it happen
twitter is the one giving it
i write a tweet that says
nancy pelosi is an alcoholic
i have it on good authority anti-policy
an alcoholic
drinks a fifth of gin every half an hour
okay
i put it on twitter you you can't sue
twitter no matter how
obvious of a lie it is because they're
just
they're just a mechanism they're just an
internet service provider you can sue
coleman
but i want to sue twitter because
they've got billions of dollars
and coleman has half a house in new
jersey okay
and if if pelosi can prove damages
by the time she gets past my mortgage
it's not going to be worth the trouble
that's why we care but we hardly care
because most
because section 230 says you're not
gonna you're it's not going to happen
but defamation is hardly ever the issue
the issue is the censorship and that's
where
the cases are getting interesting
especially now that we have
the the rogan o'hanley case that we
filed last week
what is this one rogan
roger handling known as dc drano
sued twitter but it's twitter is the
last party
in the defendant column the first party
is the secretary of state
of the state of california
rogan got documents from judicial watch
smoking gun documents showing that
under the guise of
election security
the state of california was
sending and through a consultant
and in cooperation with 22
members of the national association of
secretaries of state
all democrats sending tweets
that were selected i think by the
consultant
to twitter saying this is misleading
this is fake news a direct line from
democrats
to the big tech company no they are all
democrats
a direct line from the government there
you go to the censorship
a direct all we've heard about is
you build your own twitter the
government and twitter
are the same
the government you know
there's been lots of talk about what
kinds of accommodations have been made
we won't regulate you if you play ball
all this
that's all very sort of impressionistic
what we have here is specific political
instructions from political
activists telling
twitter and they banned
dc durano has two million
instagram followers right meaning
it did they just needed a a
a uh an excuse
he's too influential to be allowed to
continue to comment
on twitter as far as i know instagram's
not implicated in this in facebook
in this particular issue but
this is where things are going this is
where things are going so
now that's almost the first that's
a new world that's a new world and we
this is a case that we filed on thursday
and it's being routinely ignored by the
media
completely ignored if i told you fox
won't cover it
they won't fox will not cover it
wow and
i always knew that tucker carlson was
controlled opposition
so tucker so rogen and harmeet my
partner
were on tucker thursday night but fox
news won't cover it
but tucker allowed you to talk about it
tucker i take her back he's the only one
who's not controlling that position
talk you know you know these categories
are both
baloney they they
you know and it's very common on on
twitter that people want to
you know have he's a rhino
uh he oh that bill of democrats support
it the world is not black and white
and there's no question that in politics
you have to make accommodations to get
things done
with uh people from other parties and i
you know we all
have to get that people are complicated
they have
you know and like you know we were
talking before we went on who's
who's sticking their neck out for the
movement versus who's sticking his
neck out for his 401k
you know and listen most people are not
most people are just interested in i
don't want to call it a grift
making a living making a living thanks
for checking out this clip from the tim
cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members
only content segments you can't get
anywhere else go to timcast.com become a
member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you